- Good afternoon everybody
welcome to this year's
Tanner Lectures at Yale University,
hosted by the Whitney Humanities Center.
I'm Gary Tomlinson I'm the
director of the Whitney.
We're gathered of course
to hear from Achille Mbembe
who is a research professor
at the University of the Witwatersrand
in Johannesburg, South Africa.
And more specifically,
at the Wits Institute
for Social and Economic
Research, WISER as it is known
and we're delighted by the way to have
the director of WISER professor
Sarah Nuttall with us,
also today, Sarah.
(audience applauding)
I've known Professor Mbembe,
since we were colleagues at
the University of Pennsylvania
some 25 years ago and is a huge pleasure
for me to welcome him to this stage today.
I know we are in for today,
tomorrow and Thursday
not only an intellectual
feast, but something more
since Professor Mbembe
has in his many writings,
it's not too much to say,
recast the terms of post-colonial
analysis and critique.
This achievement is particularly marked
in his most recent book,
but one, Critique of Black Reason
where he leads us to understand blackness,
not only as a project of the imagination
shaped by half a
millennium of subjugation,
enslavement, exploitation, murder
but also as the condition
that all the worlds
subaltern people are subjected to today
by the forces of neoliberal capital.
But I leave further
introduction of Professor Mbembe
to my colleague Michael Denning.
To me it's left to outline
the schedule of Tanner events
over the next two days
and just say a few words
about the Tanner as an institution.
This afternoon, we hear the first
of Professor Mbembe two lectures,
afterwards you're all
invited to a reception
here at the Whitney, it's
straight down the hall
directly behind you.
Tomorrow again at five
o'clock Professor Mbembe
will present his second lecture,
and after that there will be a short
question and answer session.
And then on Thursday
morning finally, at 10:30,
we reconvene for a discussion
among Professor Mbembe,
Professor Denning and
another Yale professor
Inderpal Grewal.
At that session there will
be additional opportunity
for questions from the audience.
As to the Tanner Lectures on Human Values,
they were established
by the American scholar,
industrialist and philanthropist
Obert Clark Tanner
and his wife Grace Tanner.
For many years a professor
at the University of Utah,
and a scholar of the New Testament
educated at Harvard and Stanford,
Tanner also founded in
1927, early in his adulthood
a jewelry company in Salt Lake City.
The company later
expanded into broad areas
of human resource consulting
and employee recognition programs.
They made trophies and placards and so on
for 25 years of service
and things like that,
and from that made a whole lot of money,
and it is on the base of that corporation
that the Tanner foundation
and Grace Tanner's
philanthropic efforts are built.
These efforts include today
the Tanner Lectures at Yale,
and at a number of other
universities in the United States,
Great Britain and beyond.
The purpose Obert Tanner envisioned
for the Tanner Lectures is to advance
and reflect upon scholarly
and scientific learning
relating to human values,
in creating the lectureships
professor Tanner knowingly
left his purview very broad,
he wrote, "I see these
lectures simply as a search
"for a better understanding
of human behavior
"and human values."
"This understanding may be pursued
"for its own intrinsic worth,
"but it may also eventually
have practical consequences
"for the quality of
personal and social life."
Appointment as a Tanner lecturer
is a recognition of uncommon achievement
on outstanding abilities in the area
of human values and studies,
and we are honored to add Professor Mbembe
to the list of distinguished
scholars and humanists
whom Yale has so recognized.
At Yale, the Tanner lecturers are selected
by the President, in
consultation with the director
and executive committee of
the Whitney Humanities Center
so we're also indebted to
Yale President Peter Salovey
who will be here tomorrow night
for his assistance in bringing
today's speaker to us.
Now, it's my pleasure
to welcome to the podium
Michael Denning William,
our keen and junior professor
of American Studies and English
to introduce our speaker, Michael.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you Gary,
it's a great pleasure to
welcome Achille Mbembe
back to Yale to deliver the Tanner Lecture
Borders in the Age of Networks.
I won't repeat that he's
a research professor
with Witwatersrand, I'll just say,
I last introduced Achille
to a Yale audience in 2007,
and in the decades since he
has published three major books
and I thought start with those,
rather than going way back.
The first in 2010,
was Sortir de la Grande Nuit,
an allusion to Fanon's call
to shake off the great mantle of night.
Essai sur l'Afrique Décolonisée,
Essay, on decolonized Africa.
Not yet translated into English
it opens with an
extraordinarily, powerful,
autobiographical narrative of
a country and three cities.
First, and please excuse
my halting translations.
I hope they're accurate.
Born in the shadow of a
country without a proper name,
Cameroon the name given
by Portuguese seamen
marveling at the abundance of shrimp,
camaroe, in the river.
And born in the shadow of and I quote,
"The first age of post colonialism."
In it's childhood and adolescence,
and in the shadow of songs of lamentation
for the disavowed martyrs of
the anti-colonial struggle,
and the schoolroom anthems
of the post-colonial nation and potentate.
Then as when intellectuals, and I quote
Since the time of Fanon,
Cesaire and Senghor
having taken his masters at
the University of Yaounde
he left for Paris where he took
his doctorate at the Sorbonne and New York
where he taught at Columbia.
And where I won't summarize
his luminous pages
on what those two cities meant to him.
He became a historian not only
of the resistance in Cameroon
editing a collection of the writings
of the martyred Rueben Umnioba
and publishing in 1996,
The Birth of the Resistance
in South Cameroon.
But of the surpluses of
post-colonial Africa,
and he forged the remarkable dialectic
of historical reflection
and critical theory
that has come to characterize his style,
first on the post colony
translated into English
published 2000 and translated
into English in 2001.
But then in the last
year of the 20th century
as he puts it, he arrived in South Africa.
In the shadow and I'm quoting
here again the Maelstrom,
"In the shadow of the
Maelstrom that was apartheid,
"it's statues still standing
its streets not yet renamed
"in a city Johannesburg the
most modern, most powerful
"and most racially mixed
of African metropolis
" is a new frontier of the
continent where one finds
"almost all the
nationalities of the world."
A migrant to Johannesburg,
it is from Johannesburg
that Achelle Mbembe has
over the last two decades
reimagined our world.
In his account of Africa's
attempt to shake off
the great mantle of night,
in his extraordinary 2013 book,
Critique of Black Reason,
which has just been
translated into English.
A philosophical history of
the invention of black reason.
The Western consciousness
of Africa and blackness
in the shadow of the slave
trade and colonialism,
of the reversal of that black reason
into the black reason that is
the polyglot internationalism
of the modern black imaginary.
In figures from Garvey and
Dubois to Fanon and Mandela,
and finally to the Becoming
Black of the World.
And most recently in the 2016 book,
The Politics of Enmity,
a chapter of which has
been recently translated
in radical philosophy, a
reflection on a world dominated
by the desire for an enemy.
A desire for apartheid,
a desire for separation
and exclusion and walls, and the new forms
of nano racism and hydraulic racism,
that that world has shaped.
Throughout all his work,
he has been haunted by death and corpses.
Necropolitics has been one of
his most influential essays.
And death stretches across his work
from the cemeteries in Cameroon
to the amazing essay
on Mandela's mortality,
written together with Sara Nuttall.
However, recalling the songs
of lamentation of his grandmother,
for the son assassinated
in the resistance,
he writes that, these songs
served to accompany his shadow
and to open for him away
to a possible repose
in compensation for the
unspeakable injustice
the victim experienced after his demise.
In a similar way,
Achille Mbembe's writings
accompany the shadows of the dead
and undead of our world,
and open a way to a possible repose,
and in common as he calls it
beyond the unspeakable injustices
of a society of enmity.
Please join me in welcoming Achille Mbembe
for the first of his two Tanner lectures,
The New Global Mobility Regime.
(audience applauding)
- I would like to thank
Gary and the University
for a very gracious invitation.
As Gary said, we were both colleagues,
many years ago.
He said 25 years and I suddenly realized
that time has been
passing rather quickly,
but as you can testify,
Gary always looks very young,
both physically and in his mind.
Gary was and has been all along,
his work has been a great
inspiration for a lot of us.
I would also like to extend
my gratitude to Michael.
I like Michael very, very much,
I know he likes me too as well,
you could see with his introduction,
and I'm very glad my wife
Sarah Nuttall is here.
Perhaps, more than any other,
Ours is an epoch of fantasies.
One such fantasy is that of
total security,
or perfectly controlled,
or tightened borders,
the dream of impenetrable
and insurmountable limits
which is the same thing as the dream of
a domain without an outside.
A domain whose walls
cannot be broken through
and whose boundaries can never be crossed,
if only because they are
continuously redrawn,
displaced and pushed back.
So as the twin logics of order
and security on the one hand
and freedom and movement on the other
confront one another,
borders almost everywhere
are increasingly found
in unexpected places.
In the not-so-distant past,
borders have always been generative
of new modes of power, and
a new political reason.
Such was the case in 1884, 1885
when meeting in Berlin
for what was then known
as the Congo Conference.
14 European powers
divided Africa, among them
for the purpose of colonization.
This they did, by carving out
the entire continent and by superimposing
on pre-existing political
entities and cultures,
a hotspot of geometric boundaries
that divided it into
50 aberrant countries.
As clearly pointed out in the
general acts of the conference
this was all I quote,
"In the name of free
trade and civilization."
As Article II of that general act
of the conference specifies
I quote again,
"All flags without distinction
"of nationality shall have free access
"to the whole of the coastline
"of the territories above enumerated."
Enumerated in Article I,
"To the rivers there running into the sea
"to all the waters of the
Congo and its effluence,
"including the lakes, and to all the ports
"situated on the banks of these waters
"as well as to all the
canals which may in future
"be constructed with intent
to unite the water courses
"or lakes within the entire area
"of the territories
described in article one."
End of quote.
The said Article I, starts
with the following statement,
I quote again.
"The trade of all nations
shall enjoy complete freedom.
"Follows geographical specification
"which is at the same time
a naming of a large boundary
"and the claiming of a
huge chunk of territory
"called the basin of the Congo."
And so it goes.
A new mode of power,
a new political reason
but even more crucially
a claim made in relation to
an assemblage of territories,
territories made of rivers, of mountains,
ridges and watersheds.
Lakes, maritime zones, lines,
parallels and latitudes.
Points of demarkation and
assemblage of territories,
power is seeking to take possession of.
So at the beginning, or at
least in our colonial experience
the resident of the border,
is to attend to the problem
of the distribution of the earth.
How much the earth of land be distributed?
To whom does the earth belong?
Who can lay what type of
claim to what part of it?
To whom should be allotted what share?
Who determines its
distribution or partition?
In its colonial roots, geopolitics
is about the multiple distribution
of populations, not only human
on the body of the earth.
It is about the modes of occupation
and the distribution of the earth,
and the manner in which these modes affect
the vital forces of our kinds of beings,
human and non-human.
Yesterday borders used
to manifest themselves
in two major ways.
First, as tangible, physical features,
usually located at the
edge of state territory.
And second, as sites where discretionary
sovereign decisions were made,
in relation to whether to permit
or to exclude what,
whom, under what terms.
Nowadays, they are ever more mobile
complex, differentiated, dispersed
and fracturelized just
as they remain contested.
As more and more people
find themselves on the move,
new laws regulations, bureaucracies
and procedures are produced
in a renewed attempt
at controlling and
regulating the movements
through and across the
border escapes of our world,
and in an effort at setting
the terms under which
foreign bodies might enter, reside,
work, settle and perhaps integrate
in countries other than their own.
Migration policy which is mostly
about the control of human mobility,
is once again seen as a
key index of sovereignty
in a world of flows, risks and threats.
Furthermore, border work,
work of instituting, enacting, boundaries,
understood mostly as powers highly
and even imperfect and yet incessant labor
to contain mobility, border work
is evermore incorporated
into everyday ways of life.
It is enhanced by
numerous security schemes
and technologies supposedly configured
to operate objectively.
Objectively, that is without
prejudice or discrimination.
Such security technologies are enlisted
in what is increasingly an
automated calculation of threats
the key feature of our times.
They are configured in
such a way as to track
unveil and sort, that which is hidden,
that which must be detected and inspected,
that which is out of
place or unauthorized.
Concealed identities, apparent movements
categories of potential enemies,
actual human bodies in this
age of generalized suspicion.
Indeed, this is also an
epoch when the human body
or more precisely that
body that is not mine
re-emerges as potentially dangerous
and meshed as it is with various figures
of threat and insecurity.
Threat to cultural identity,
threat to the welfare of state,
threat to public order and even
an existential threat to our way of life
and our way of being.
According to the new,
old security rationale,
although everybody is
potentially dangerous
until proven otherwise,
some categories of bodies and persons
carry almost by definition
more risks than others.
Even at the most vulnerable state,
they fundamentally endanger our lives.
As such they must be the
object of renewed profiling
classification, and
isolation or even eliminated
in line with a long history in modernity
that ties together the targeting,
quarantining, restriction
and even extermination of populations
that have been marked as abnormal
or have been profoundly dishonored.
The obsession with the
borders of the human body
in particular the borders
of that body that is not mine,
has in turn unleashed a
renewed algorithmic production
of its nude image by fully body scanners
and examination screens.
At a time when security
is equated with visibility
and concealment with threat.
What the body looks
like, what its parts are,
what are its shapes and forms?
What objects is it concealing?
And what others should delete.
These are questions,
the new matrix of threat and risk
is forcing us to ask with urgency.
So over the last 15 years,
a huge amount of empirical work
has been done in relation
to both borders and migration,
and it is not my intention
to rehearse it here.
The wealth of data already accumulated
has helped sharpen our
understanding of mobility
and of borders, of capture,
immobility and flight.
It has also highlighted
the extent to which various processes
are unfolding simultaneously,
the freeing of internal mobility for some
and the hardening of external
boundaries for others.
Phenomenon such as the re-specialization
of state sovereignty,
the securitization of migration,
the emerging of criminal justice
and immigration policing.
The extraterritorialization
of certain practices
related to migration management.
These and other processes
have been the object
of extensive and careful descriptions.
Drawing from this material,
it seems to me it's now possible
to rethink what is at stake
when the biopolitics
of mobility intersects
with the geopolitics of our times.
The kind of political reason
that is produced at this intersection.
In other words, what is it
that contemporary migratory struggles
tell us about the border
regimes of our times
and the apparatuses of control,
and capture of bodies, capture of motion,
capture of speed and ultimately
capture of life itself
in the current conjuncture.
These are some of the questions
I would like to examine
during these lectures.
I will be using at times interchangeably
such terms as borders,
migration, mobility, movement.
These are obviously technical concepts,
borders are at the front line
of present-day geopolitics,
they are also the sites where
sovereignty is the most
subject to reanimation.
To be sure the long-established concept
of territorial, physical
or political boundary of a state,
still has relevance in a world
in which lines and
cleaves and compartments
have not entirely disappeared.
The lines that continue to separate us
are still there, but boundaries or borders
and no longer conceived
merely as walls or fences.
Even when they manifest themselves
as tangible physical features,
located at the edge of state territory
they are increasingly
understood, as a contingent
assemblage of social practices
subject to change.
They are increasingly understood
as relational arrangements of bodies
in spaces, and not only as, as containers.
In fact, as argued by many,
the discretionary sovereign decisions
that are taken at borders,
ultimately the result
of various interactions
between border guards, detection devices,
sniffer dogs, humans, non-humans.
Bordering actions or
practices in that sense,
represent a provisional stabilization
of various forces and devices.
Forces with competing
understandings of threat,
forces whose function is to enact
or perform security in the face of cunning
and supposedly merciless enemy others.
And so a border in this sense,
is the result of how
mobility controlle regime's
use difference to constitute
different spatial practices.
So, the point I'm trying to make is that,
as a matter of fact,
there is no homogenizing
border logic, there isn't.
Difference and territoriality
are always practiced in
fractured and passion ways,
at least that is one thing we draw
from the voluminous amount of research
I was referring to.
This having been said and taken together,
these terms, borders, mobility,
movement and so on.
These terms all mean one thing.
The multiple distributions
of human populations
on the body of the earth,
that's how I understand these terms.
They all refer to the same thing.
The monitoring of the
movements of populations
that stipulate on the
surface of the earth,
or that happened to settle
somewhere for various reasons.
But in my understanding,
what is ultimately at stake
in the current planetary
politics of mobility,
is the drawing of the
new limits of the earth.
In this context, the
main function of borders
is precisely to push outside,
to throw outside
that body that is not mine.
Or to put it in Heidegger's terms,
"The wrong people,
"with the wrong blood."
That's Heidegger's expression.
In this sense, the border
has the status of law
to be sure border does not
only exclude or separate,
it can also connect, but overall,
a border is in the last
instance always conceived
in its disjunctive use.
It always refers, in the last instance
to those populations
coming from the outside,
and in relation to which it must act
as a filter, or which
it actually threatens.
So, I start from the assumption that
any form of mobility finds
its limit at the border,
the border is that which
interrupts movement or motion
and in modernity, border control
has played two decisive functions,
has been a key device
in the planetary
management of populations.
It has also been a key vector
for the configuration of various degrees
of subjecthood, flow and
distribution of bodies,
the constitution of
subjects without rights.
And a preeminent sight
for the execution of state violence.
The limit where life matters the most.
So, the questions I'm
asking are the following,
to what new existences,
do borders bear witness
in our contemporary world?
Why, in the confrontation with borders,
why do so many people,
why are they compelled
towards experimenting
at the limits of the livable?
This way of framing the issue
is markedly different
from the three approaches
that have of late dominated
debates on mobility
in the age of borders and networks.
Of the various strands that have of late
dominated such debates,
three in particular should be highlighted.
The first trend, centered around
the concept of precarity
or precarious lives,
has sought to delineate
the interconnections
between neoliberal work
and welfare regimes.
Immigration controls and exploitation
or hyper exploitation of
international migrant labor.
Today, indeed more than
at any other moment
of our recent history,
migrants are centrally implicated
in highly precarious work experiences
at the bottom end of labor markets.
Literally, in western
capitalist countries,
but also in various
parts of the global south
as the case in South Africa,
as the case in Gulf countries
and so forth and so on.
The concept of precarity
has been mobilized
in an effort to describe
those life world's
epitomized by migrant existence,
an existence that is inflected
with uncertainty and instability.
It is a concept that has been understood
both as a descriptor and as a condition.
Condition, let me repeat
which itself is a consequence
of neoliberal globalization,
and ready transformations
in the world of work
and precarity in this instance,
has been used as a key
explanatary framework
for new forms of workplace exploitation.
The idea that the life of the migrant
at the bottom end of the labor ladder,
is the metaphor of precarious life.
This idea refers to something more
than a position in the labor market.
Precarity has also been understood
as something intertwined,
with other areas of life
something almost existential
which speaks to the inability to predict
one's fate, or to enjoy
the degree of stability,
on which to build social relations
and feelings of affection.
Precarity has finally been understood
as a condition of structural insecurity,
as a consequence of differential exposure
to violence and suffering that emanates
from socio-political context.
That's the first way in which
the question of mobility,
borders, migrancy
has been dealt with through the lens
of this concept of precarity.
A second strand of debates on migration
has focused on emerging geographies
of detention, imprisonment
and confinement.
In other words, the cultural
landscapes of our world.
The idea here is that
a migrant, a body on the move
in a way that is not authorized,
is almost by definition likely to end up
in one form or another of a prison.
To be detained, confined, deported
is part of the options he
or she permanently faces.
The driving concept in this case,
has been that of
categorical vulnerability.
Indeed, during 2009 alone, in the US,
approximately 380,000 people
spent time in the vast
and continuosly expanding
migrant detention system.
According to Detention Watch Network,
this system consisted then,
of approximately 350 facilities
operating at an annual cost
of more than $1.7 billion.
In other countries, such as the UK,
the use of migrant detention
in the form of Asylum
screening units, has expanded.
Across the European Union,
detention facilities have
similarly proliferated
and now, number in the hundreds
while Australia has intensified
detention practices, on and offshore.
In short, the world has witnessed
a significant expansion,
of landscapes of detention
over the last decade.
So has been the growth
of detention structures
along transnational routes,
travelled by migrants
in the journeys through northern Africa,
Eastern Europe, Indonesia
and Central America.
Simultaneously, detention and deportation
have become more than ever
interlocked industries.
In this context, an important strand
of studies on borders and mobility,
has been preoccupied
with the extent to which
the categorical vulnerability
to which migrants and undocumented people
are subjected, to what extent
is this category legally produced.
Then there is a third strand,
which has focused on the warehousing
of refugees and asylum seekers.
Here too, the number
of people in the world
fleeing conditions of war,
violence, disasters, economic distress
and environmental collapse
has been swelling.
In 2014, the number of
forcibly displaced people
in the world, surpassed the record number
of people displaced in the aftermath
of the Second World War.
I think the latest figures, we have had,
last year (mumbles),
we are told that there
are 65 million people.
65 million refugees in search of asylum
in our world as we speak.
From whatever angle one examines it,
the border therefore remains
a bio political space.
And in a number of incidences,
border crossing has become
a matter of life and death.
In such a context,
humanitarian border works goal,
is not to abolish border controls
or to contest the border
as a space of exercise of sovereign power,
but to turn it into a space both of rescue
and of provision of basic emergency care.
The rescaling and outsourcing of borders
is not only happening inland,
it is also happening offshore
especially on deserts and islands,
where high measures of enclosure
aim at shutting down paths to asylum
but containing people
trying to reach sovereign territories
in M smaller and more remote locations.
Such is notably the case
with Europe, Southern peripheries.
In particular, the two Spanish enclaves
of Ceuta and Melilla.
In Melilla, following the arrival
of the first group of African migrants,
Spain built a three metre high fence,
12 kilometres square in Melilla
which is a 12 kilometer square and cleave,
which is located in fact
in northeastern Morocco
which has been under Spanish sovereignty
since the late 15th century.
Few years later, the EU financed
the construction of a six metre high,
three-tier fence, equipped
with manned control posts,
infrared cameras, acoustic sensors
and motion detectors.
The EU also put pressure on Morocco
to control its side of the border.
In response, Morocco initiated
regular military cleanup operations,
most of which consisted in
putting migrants in tracks,
take them to the city of Oujda,
further down south near
the border with Algeria
and dumping them there or in the desert.
The key component of the
strategy of outsourcing,
European border control
has expanded outwardly with the assistance
of third countries, at the same time
as internal border control
is strengthened through
surveillance agencies,
increased rates of deportation
and the proliferation
of internment centers.
As far as outsourcing is concerned,
the Moroccan government has been building
its own barbed wire fence,
a fence partially financed
by the EU subsidies and allocated to Spain
for border control.
The same thing is happening as we speak
throughout the Sahara Desert,
in places such as Niger, Libya of course,
Burkina Faso and along
the coast of Senegal.
Typical of the distinctly
neoliberal articulation
between securitization
and free-market internationalism,
the same countries that are determined
to secure their borders,
are actively engaged in the construction
of free trade partnerships
with the very same neighbors
from whom they seek to protect themselves.
Which raises of course
the question of selective permeability,
in other words
of whose interest the opening
or closing of border serves.
I could go on and on the case
of these two enclaves and Islands
or talk a bit more about the deserts,
but the point I really want to make
is that the three strands, I have evoked
all point towards one thing.
They point towards the fact that
reworking and rescaling of borders
is in the making.
And it is in the making
at a planetary level, globally.
It is in the making as a result
of the emergence of a new mobility regime,
one which is planetary in scale.
And I would now like to say a few words
about these new mobility regime.
I have gone to some length describing
the ways in which Islands
enter into these new calculus of mobility,
I also alluded to the extent to which
deserts are implicated
in the same process.
I would now like to focus
on what we should more broadly call
the liquid frontier.
Because the liquid frontier is
at the vanguard of the
redefinition of sovereignty
in the contemporary world.
In order to understand
the liquid frontier,
and how it reorganizes sovereignty
and contributes to the making
of a new global mobility regime,
an excursion through Carl Schmitt's
Nomos of The Earth, is necessary.
If only because for Schmitt,
the fundamental distinction on which
geopolitics has been predicated.
Geopolitics in the sense of
the distribution of the earth,
and the distribution of the earth
which are equated with mobility
and borders at the beginning.
Evenly because for him,
geopolitics has been predicated
on a binary division, between a solid land
where territories can
be clearly demarcated
and where order may be imposed,
and the sea.
So land on the one hand,
the sea on the other
where borders according to Schmidt,
in any case can be neither traced
nor held, and where in Schmitt's imaginary
freedom reigns absolute.
That's how he understand, the sea
Of course this is an
idealization of the sea.
Sea as an empty, almost abstract
and frictionless geometric space,
open to navigation.
A question of navigation
which we found too
when I was referring to
the carving of of Africa
during the Berlin conference.
So this idealization of
course, it has been critiqued.
In fact, as we not now realize,
oceans hardly cover space evenly.
Oceans are in fact a fabric,
that is full of holes,
it is stitched together out of pieces.
The sea is if we want a tangle of strings,
that we know now.
Schmitt might not have known about this
but at least now we have the advantage
of knowing better than he did.
But the liquid territory
of the sea nevertheless
offers a number of particularities.
First, because
water covers over 70% of the
surface area of our planet,
many frontiers in the world today
are located in the sea, first point.
Second,
the sea is
what we can get
in terms of the idea of
an absolute boundary.
All boundaries are relative,
but if we were to imagine,
if only for a second,
what an absolute boundary might look like,
we have to look not on
land but on the sea.
It is the only absolute boundary
because it alone,
blocks the continuous
expansion of other people, it alone.
Deleuze and Guattari
believed that the desert
does that better than the sea,
but these are discussions
we can explore later.
So the sea does that, and
yet it can be domesticated
to bring people into contact.
It enables circulation,
while adding friction to movement,
while adding friction to life.
The other interesting thing with the sea
I lay down all of these
and then I would draw the
conclusion at the end,
and you see where I'm going.
The third interesting thing with the sea
according to Schmitt,
is that of course
it is stirred by currents and waves,
and by being stirred by currents and waves
it seems to erase any trace
including traces of the past,
or to relegate and contain
them and it's very bottom.
And because of these
apparent permanent erasure of all traces,
the sea seems to maintain everything
in a kind of permanent
present according to Schmitt.
Furthermore, still with Schmitt,
part of what characterizes
this vast expanse
is the lack of stable
habitation on its surface.
I mean this was probably before
the oil digging,
oil extraction,
which today allows for,
I mean in habitations on the surface,
but we are not yet there with Schmitt
he's still writing at the time,
when this doesn't seem at all possible.
And because of this lack of
stable habitation I quote him.
"Events at sea, occur mostly
outside of the public gaze
"and thus remain unaccounted for."
There's a lack of accountability
as a characteristic feature
of what happens at sea.
Even more importantly,
throughout modernity
maritime governance,
has always oscillated between two pools.
On the one hand, the desire to divide up
the waters of the earth,
in a way that would mirror
the carving up of territorial
boundaries on land,
and on the other hand,
the vision of the ocean
has opened to free navigation,
the so-called free seas.
Hugo Grotius wrote about in his text
Mare Liberum.
Whatever the case,
Smith was
wrong, we've been wrong,
he wasn't wrong.
He got stuck let's put it like that,
with his distinction,
with his Land, Sea binary.
What has happened of late
is that the new modes
of regulation of human mobility,
have tried
to go beyond these land, sea binary,
by being attuned more than ever before
to the vertical dimensions
of maritime spaces.
And in so doing, we are nowadays
able to decipher a much more complex
form of governance, than
the simple opposition
between territorial control,
and deterritorialized flows.
What I mean by this is that,
in the new regimes of mobility,
many have come to the
realization that, in fact
territorial control can go hand in hand
with details deterritorialized flows.
What we have today, therefore
is a far more complex
jurisdictional regime
and mode of governance
in which the rights and obligations
that compose modern state
sovereignty on the land,
are decoupled from each other
and applied to a varying degrees,
depending on a spatial extent
in this big issue in question.
This is what Saskia Sassen calls
Embundled Sovereignty.
In this partial sovereignty of regime,
intersect with ever
shifting lines of control
in which routes and
traffic have become key.
What does it mean?
It means that in the making
of the new regime of mobility,
motion has been put at the center.
And if you want to control
the migration of people,
what you have to follow
as carefully as possible and trace,
is the movement of people along routes
and intersections along their journeys.
So sovereignty and governance
attempt now to be exercised
on routes and traffic
to follow those routes, to police them
while policing in the same way
high seas are policed.
So,
sovereignty in this case has
to do with the negotiation
of the inextricable articulation
between freedom and control
which is characteristic
indeed of forms of mobility,
governance in neoliberal societies.
And these sets of lines
they also simply coexist
in fact, the carving up of
partial sovereignty regimes
is the very basis for
governance in motion.
I have used the sea to
show the extent to which
it has become a laboratory,
in which contemporary modes
of mobility control have been devised
experimented with, which are now being
brought to bear on the land.
So what used to be done
exclusively at sea,
is now done on the land.
As at sea, border functions on the land
have been decoupled from the limits
of the territorial border,
and are becoming increasingly
dispersed and mobile,
able to follow ever shifting routes.
That's what is the kernel
of the new mobility regime.
Now, one of the most
significant transformations
in terms of the geopolitics
of mobility, is without that,
the blurring of inside-outside,
and the extent to which
borders have been externalized,
and the border has become
a transnational assemblage.
A number of authors speak in this regard
about the emergence of a
territorially extended,
increasingly informal
and itinerant bordering,
assemblage of institutions,
state authorities,
policies that react to dynamic
and turbulent migratory movements.
At the same time the outsourcing,
offshoring and extractive
realization of border work,
has led to a special illegal stretching
of the domains of migration control,
and a redefinition of the jurisdictions
and authorities traditionally associated
with border management.
We see it in places such
as Senegal, Mauritania,
Niger, Burkina Faso, Morocco,
Algeria, Libya,
where
the shifting performance
of sovereignty entails
the ability for the security
forces of European countries
to act in tandem with
forces of these third States,
in an attempt at cutting
of the roots of migration.
Of course, all of this
raises all kinds of dilemmas
these forms of mobile sovereignty,
legal and institutional foundations
for such programs remains unclear
particularly with the near permanent
operational border control policing
for forces
are involved in other states.
Now, let me move on,
and come back to the question of the body,
with which I started.
I indicated that the rescaling of borders
has entailed a global expansion
of security infrastructure,
ranging from physical and virtual walls
to the deployment of drones
and military hardware
to monitor and secure space.
I argued that a novel migration regime
is emerging which requires,
as I tried to show
through the reference to the sea
which requires a nonlinear
understanding of territory.
I also argued that the insight
can now be outside,
the sea on land, and the land on sea,
and what we used to take as close
can be far away and vice versa,
all of this geometry is fast changing
and it's changing as a consequence
to old models of sovereignty
understood at an earlier period
as control of people, taxes,
and discrete territories.
What I would like to add now
as do with the extent to which
in a world of technology enabled flows,
sovereignty over discrete territories
has become almost by
definition incomplete.
Many governments especially in the North
have understood that,
in order to govern the movement
of people across borders,
it is absolutely crucial
to first classify them.
Today one, of the most efficient way
to achieve such a goal,
is through the harvesting
and strategic use
of electronic personal data.
The purpose of classification
is to bring back bodies
into a zone of calculation
and manageability.
This is the reason why
in the new regime of human
mobility I'm referring to,
bordering practices have become digitized
through the automation of data
collection and data analysis.
So what is being collected,
genetic information
it stored in electronic form
in searchable bases,
physiological features
unique to individuals
such as fingerprints,
patterns of the iris and the retina.
Veins of the hand,
physionomic features
such as voice patterns
are transformed via algorithms,
to produce so-called templates.
These templates in turn are stored
in centralized databases,
that are accessed
whenever necessary.
And templates are,
when they are not stored centrally,
they are put on a chip,
inserted into all kinds of documents
such as passport and identicals.
So in this context to classify,
consists in converging the data
from integrated bases,
with biometric identifiers
such as those that I have mentioned.
And classification in this instance,
relies obviously on a
series of dividing practices
in which the subject is broken up
into calculable risk factors.
In other words to classify,
which is a very old exercise
but to classify today,
is to categorize populations
into degrees of riskiness,
and classification mostly has to do
with a pre-emptive fixing of identities.
So, thanks to the biometric turn,
governments are embedding
the regulatory functions
in various networks of global flows,
with the help of digital technologies
so that sovereignty, prerogatives,
can travel with the flows.
So to old models
based on the actual physical control
of discrete territories,
they are grafting a new model
of mobile and flowing sovereignty.
In this new model, linear border functions
are dislocated and pushed both outward
into as I said other states territories,
and inward, into national societies.
Now, this new border regime
moving towards the end now
has produced several
significant spatial outcomes.
Borders have become more mobile
but more importantly borders
have become portable.
Thus, opening the entire
space of the globe
to potential bordering processes.
What I mean by that is that,
borders have no limits.
There are no longer limits
to bordering processes.
There has been an increase
in bordering instances,
as people can now encounter
borders in various forms
in a multitude of locales
within their daily lives.
The nature of an individual's encounter
with borders has also changed,
since this is often mediated
by diverse digital devices
and managed more and
more by private actors.
So, border control has
become more individualized,
more molecular almost similar
as digitization allows surveillance
to zero in on the smaller
spaces such as the body,
and continuously monitor the body.
Now, the question is the following,
why is it that border security practices
have taken such a keen interest
in the connection between
the human body and identity
as a means of achieving
detailed control of a movement?
This is the case because the human body
is seen as an indisputable anchor,
to which data can be safely secured.
As a result, we are witnessing
a gradually extending entertwinement
of individual, physical characteristics
with information systems.
The process that has served
to deepen faith in data,
as a means of risk management,
and faith in the body
as a source of absolute identification.
The idea is that the body remains,
the truth of the individual.
If we want to know who you are,
we better open your body.
So digital devices work they are doing
is similar to work of dissection,
this worries a stake in the extension
of rhetoric border, into multiple organs
of social life in particular
into the human body.
The most efficient way
to regulate mobile bodies
is to turn them into portable bodies.
Let me conclude, the argument
I wanted to make tonight
was pretty straightforward.
The function of the border of any border,
is to simultaneously divide and define,
and in so doing, to generate
new sets of relationships
between the social special entities
and the actual bodies
they bring into existence.
Borders do not simply enclose,
they also provide an instrument,
to gain access to, or bar access to
an evenly geographically
distributed resources.
As I will show tomorrow,
the tension between
mobility and immobility,
is itself intrinsic to the
workings of global capital.
I was particularly interested
in the question of the body at the border,
and the borders of the body,
especially that body that is not mine.
Most of the bodies in motion
in our contemporary world,
the multiplicity of bodies
attempting to break through the wall,
are engaged in an old struggle,
the struggle to sustain life
under catastrophic conditions.
Rendered superfluous,
by the volatile forces
and flows of capital,
they are desperately
trying to escape places
that have been rendered uninhabitable.
Catastrophic conditions should be defined,
as those under which each
life and every breath
suddenly acquires an utmost value,
called as they are
in the Nexus of
vulnerability and emergency.
What a body, is and
what a body might become
find the limit precisely
at that border of
vulnerability and emergency.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(audience clapping)
(soft music)